un barco sobrecargado brazos levantados
al cielo una fotografía que interroga
fue tomada de día varias horas antes del
naufragio Cómo es que no se evitó la
tragedia que ocurrió más tarde en medio
de la noche se había lanzado una llamada
de ayuda desde el barco y se habían
transmitido las coordenadas GPS por la
tarde la agencia Europea de vigilancia
frontex Incluso sobrevoló el navío es
seguro que han visto el barco y desde el
momento que está sobrecargado se puede
considerar que está en peligro las
autoridades griegas afirman que no hubo
intervención porque los pasajeros
habrían rechazado la ayuda ofrecida por
frontex el problema es que la agencia
Europea de guardacostas ha perdido
credibilidad desde la publicación hace
un año de un informe condenatorio que
provocó la renuncia de su antiguo
director ejecutivo frontex ha sido
acusada de hacer la vista gorda ante la
expulsión de migrantes por parte de las
autoridades griegas una práctica ilegal
llamada pushback que se supone que la
agencia europea debería prevenir lo que
no se menciona y en lo que voy a
insistir es que cuando hablamos de
pushback no se trata solo de
devoluciones legales también es
violencia es decir que los inmigrantes
que son arrestados por la guardia
costera griega son golpeados
sistemáticamente los obligan a
desnudarse para hacer registrados en las
cavidades se recupera todo su dinero y
luego se les abandonan el mar Por qué
sorprenderse cuando los migrantes
potencialmente rechazan la ayuda que
proporcionarían los guardacostas griegos
en un contexto como este
hasta ahora las autoridades griegas
Siempre han negado las acusaciones
habituales de malos tratos documentadas
por varias ong violencia que también
anima a los migrantes a tomar rutas cada
vez más peligrosas hacia Europa este
barco partió de tobruck en el este de
Libia una ruta inusual para llegar a
Italia
Pero por qué vamos a tomar esta ruta es
solo para evitar a los guardacostas
griegos y esperar tener mejor suerte
para llegar a Italia sin ser capturados
varias ong reclaman una política de
rescate ambiciosa por parte de los
estados desde 2014 más de 20.000 hombres
mujeres y niños han muerto en esta parte
del mediter